Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
When an artist is in the process of creating
digital media, such as populating a virtual
world for an animation movie or a video game,
or even in graphic design, the artist often
requires a large number of textures for these
kinds of works.
Concrete walls, leaves, fabrics are materials
that we know well from the real world and
sometimes the process of obtaining textures
is as simple as paying for a texture package
and using it.
But the problem quite often occurs that we
wish to fill an entire road with a concrete
texture, but we only have a small patch at
our disposal.
In this case, the easiest and worst solution
is to copy-paste this texture over and over,
creating really unpleasant results that are
quite repetitive and suffer from seams.
So what about an AI-based technique that looks
at a small patch, and automatically continues
it in a way that looks natural and seamless.
This is an area within computer graphics and
AI that we call texture synthesis.
Periodic texture synthesis is simple, but
textures with structure are super difficult.
The selling point of this particular work
is that it is highly efficient at taking into
consideration the content and symmetries of
the image.
For instance, it knows that it has to take
into consideration the concentric nature of
the wood rings when synthesizing this texture,
and it can also adapt to the regularities
of this water texture and create a beautiful,
high-resolution result.
This is a neural-network based technique,
so first, the question is, what should the
training data be?
Let's take a database of high-resolution images.
Let's cut out a small part and pretend that
we don't have access to the bigger image and
ask a neural network to try to expand this
small cutout.
This sounds a little silly, so what is this
trickery good for?
Well, this is super useful because after the
neural network has expanded the results, we
now have a reference result in our hands that
we can compare to and this way, teach the
network to do better.
Note that this architecture is a generative
adversarial network, where two neural networks
battle each other.
The generator network is the creator that
expands the small texture snippets, and the
discriminator network takes a look and tries
to tell it from the real deal.
Over time, the generator network learns to
be better at texture synthesis, and the discriminator
network becomes better at telling synthesized
results from real ones.
Over time, this rivalry leads to results that
are of extremely high quality.
And as you can see in this comparison, this
new technique smokes the competition.
The paper contains a ton of more results and
comparisons, and one of the most exhaustive
evaluation sections I've seen in texture synthesis
so far.
I highly recommend reading it.
If you would like to see more episodes like
this, make sure to pick up one of the cool
perks we offer through Patreon, such as deciding
the order of future episodes, or getting your
name in the video description of every episode
as a key supporter.
We also support cryptocurrencies like Bitcoin,
Ethereum and Litecoin.
We had a few really generous pledges in the
last few weeks.
I am quite stunned to be honest, and I regret
that I cannot come in contact with these Fellow
Scholars.
If you can contact me, that would be great,
if not, thank you so much everyone for your
unwavering support.
This is just incredible.
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!